[Music]
in plot twist news a I like pot twists
I like home I'm waiting here what is how
did you do that you see inhaled in your
[ __ ] nostrils closed
what massino's Java pants funny no
what's a deviated septum deviated I know
but it was a real thing that's connected
your septum is the cartilage in the
middle and it's like a hole right yeah
yeah it's not exactly are you doing I
can't there's nothing good dogs all
today we could do it we probably all fur
you have sinus issues no sinus issues I
have to look like the Grey Poupon man as
I do it
oh really cuz they decide in movies
making fun of if I never knew though
there's a roundworm limousine boys
pulling up drive by mustard bangin
of all time anyway submitted by a was up
JK we shouldn't have selected this
person that was a lame [ __ ] name this
person's lame it's a man you should
never I selected them there is faces
worn out things is they drive to
7-eleven they buy a scratch or they
didn't win again maybe tomorrow will be
a better day
no oh yeah a cop called to break up a
fight in a hotel finds a shocking
surprise okay I the way a cop who was
called to break up a fight at a hotel
finds a shocking surprise oh there was a
piece of [ __ ] surprise you'd be probably
like oh like a domestic abuse thing and
then you get there's like oh no they
just [ __ ] all over the place do keep
your where I think Bobby Lee was in that
room oh my god maybe there was a blow-up
doll and the guy's got a ball gag and
he's tied up
okay what's the ball club doll about
walking in like direction the guy's like
hey I was trying to [ __ ] [ __ ] the
blow-up doll and I tied myself up in the
night realize oh wait doesn't seem like
it'd be too noisy that's way better
Oh
so there are these three aspiring State
Police Cadets aspiring police that's
healthy roadies they're not even police
officers wait aspiring police cadets
so there's firing the beat cadets yeah
aspiring to aspires with the face
someday I'll be a cadet they're aspiring
to be cops right yeah they probably
wrote it I don't know you smart ass
we're all having fun
I'm a fun killer Steve that's Miami
you're you're immunizing are fun yeah so
then they just you know they got little
food with drinking like this girl oh
they could dance yeah oh and they ended
up just going to this hotel
this happened in Mexico so northeastern
Mexico you know how to party
north yeah East that's when the hotel
people they ended up hearing like a
whole bunch of squeaking noises my bed
and like lot of moaning and so this turn
into a threesome right time until the
people in the hotel they started hearing
like bottles everywhere in like some
sort of like fighting happening so they
called the cops and then the cops go
into the room and they're [ __ ]
everywhere one of the police officers
one of the police officers realizes he's
a girlfriend that it's it's a wife
police officer and his wife is training
to be a police
and what the whole fight started was
because the one of the two women which I
don't know who it was
there's two women it was two girls and a
guy ah [ __ ] threesome we want two
guards in exactly thank you they they
were fighting over the dick right they
were because oh really
one of them got jealous that the dude
was giving more attention to the other
one so then the two girls started
fighting that's when it turned into a
brawl gonna be - why did you call it the
devil's threesome yeah I'm the only
acceptable form of a threesome I don't
know the devil's threesome is the two
guys one girl thing yeah dude another
girl I don't know first tacos Thank You
girl with [ __ ] does it mean I have
two holes and the guy oh I guess the
guys have two balls but I could I can't
fill it so it doesn't matter
you don't have to fill it guys can fill
mine holes but I can't throw two guys
holes why don't you want your whole site
so close my holes that design one hole
to be filled and that's it you're just
bicurious it's okay making the face
Te'o's make you the face because they
were wanted both holes filled so I
started picturing it but I'm like you
guys are on the same team we're on the
same team we can't eat [ __ ] and you
guys can okay go eat your [ __ ] [ __ ]
you guys you really want to spread [ __ ]
lips and lick and I do it badly you want
that easier he's like missing out so I
can't go as fast your biceps alright
they look [ __ ] weak you can't do it
for a long time come on do it like that
what's the part you're breaking it
like coming out your titty yeah you like
drinking the two smallest dicks in the
world
Joe like can you make the face and
you're like the face you've been making
the whole time you're doing this [ __ ] I
don't know why I'm no worse off my face
is like you're not fine
you said you were the fun killer yeah I
don't know retain your milk your milk
good she's get in trouble what happened
so let me show you some photos
Oh Hotel why am I still expecting there
to be [ __ ] on a photo I expected to see
no I'm saying when you tell me I'm gonna
we're talking about three from the whole
time and sex stuff I have some photos
and then it's a [ __ ] building click
right please no he's Mexican he just
can't wear barefoot in the inside throw
speed you're catching on yeah she
doesn't want to get toe fungus that's
cool
yeah it's another thing Mexican well
like when I lived in Mexico my whole
family they shower with flip-flops yep
in their own shop in our own shower
right why they don't they just bleach it
so on I mean they do too we're really
clean people but it's just because we're
just so extra about it flip-flops are
someone needs to tell Mexicans that
every bleach at the shower flip-flops
yeah um shower flip-flops yeah at the
spa yes same one yeah but I don't do it
it's cuz it's uncomfortable I like being
bashful I'm sorry I don't shower what's
it like to feel everything but the
showers in Mexico were different on
about now but they were different
because it was like all tile and it was
like open it didn't have
once I went to yeah like it didn't have
a door like you like it's a room and it
just doesn't close oh and when I go to
the agents pause when I get to my shower
station I take my things off and then I
shout out there oh I don't do that it's
a very Asian thing for a spa I always
take my shoes off and pretty agent photo
mom so what I'm told in your face I
don't know who the wife is it's the
police yeah yeah it's like damn yeah the
one that wasn't getting them look at me
she's like wait she's like you want me
to come you gotta take a picture of me
while you're choking me there looks like
to her though I thought you meant a face
I can't give you the fact I don't know
them all right and then they were also
reporting that when the police officer
went in and realized that it was his
wife that he almost like fainted so he
had no idea she was a cheating [ __ ] no
cuz he would have left her
that's another woman yeah but they're
all could that cuz they just remember
the dream I had where I was going down
on a girl and it was so nasty well it's
not well your brain wanted it to happen
God my body didn't because I was gagging
in my dream awesome would you let a girl
go down on you no not in that dream it
was a nightmare she called it a
nightmare there you go there you go
I never had any gay dreams I don't care
what girl went down I mean that's
different than kissing my drew by Perry
lips
that's very bicurious of you very nice
I'm very progressive I wouldn't want to
go down you're like some amounts of
mouse that yeah I like it
face [ __ ] nice but you're like I can't
kiss a girl cuz she's too softly yeah
yeah but she could kiss my vagina
Casey Pryor has this office looking
that's I've ever seen my whole life he
has amazing lips yeah Casey looks like
he's good like you kissing a [ __ ]
mattress but he's gonna scrub yeah it's
actual song round so now his lips are
good
but like you I could draw his lips
freehand right now anything for him yes
I could I know that now
you drive
[Laughter]